[Music]
welcome back to this year sixth annual
Halloween special I'm doing another
video with this guy it's good to be here
we're talking about everyone's favorite
child murderer yeah he's my favorite
yeah he's great he's phenomenal but is
he your favorite child murderer or your
favorite murderer of children because
Michael Myers might be my favorite child
murderer I think Freddy is my favorite
okay yeah he also has more dark
undertones that yeah people don't talk
about it anymore but he'd like kids a
little bit too much it's a possibility
there's definitely some some serious
undertones to the original and some of
the subsequent sequels that is sort of
become more of a just cliche slasher
thing now I never got to see this movie
as a kid because my parents like they
let me watch certain movies that were
rated R but only if they were edited for
content on TV like when I was really
little like I saw diehard and all the
classic rated R movies but only if it
was on TV so I felt like they're really
horrible edits you know like the fake
words inserted and stuffs in the nick of
time
hey McClane I got a first-class unit
here swap teaming aw we don't need any
Monday Morning Quarterback forget Monday
morning my wife saw one of those damn
planes these guys are fooling with that
puts me on the playing field and if you
removed your fat feet when I told you to
we wouldn't get hit deep in snow right
now
[Music]
yippie Kay yay mr. Falcon the pan and
scan
oh the pan and scans full screen I don't
know how I ever dealt with that but I
never got to see Nightmare on Elm Street
because my parents always I think maybe
because of it like the subtext we just
refer to they were always a little bit
so I saw for the first time as an adult
yeah and which I kind of loved because
they were there were a handful of movies
that I got to experience for the first
time with like a fully developed brain
and so I was able to appreciate them
more I think than if I had been like 5
years old or something really I see my
three older sisters made me watch this
movie we watched it I feel like once a
week we even have the NES Nightmare on
Elm Street game were a little bad to fly
out and kill you ever since I was a kid
when I think of terrifying visuals when
I used to have nightmares or or walk
through my house it had a basement and
this is the movie that terrified me of
going into basements that boiler room
that old glove sitting in the basement
this is the movie that I think is the
core of everything wrong with me and I
appreciate it for those those reasons
well that's great I'm glad to know that
now I expect quite a bit actually it
does yeah and my weird fascination with
Christmas sweaters I love this
soundtrack to this movie - oh yeah it's
amazing soundtrack yeah you have
listened for soundtracks in horror films
you have Halloween and then you have
Nightmare on Elm Street to me those are
the two quintessential soundtracks and
perfect scores for the antagonists of
the film what was it with like the 70s
and 80s and musical scores for horror
movies I mean jaws and Halloween all
these movies that had like these
incredible themes that we still hum
today like this one or even the one
where the little girls one
- he's coming from you three four yeah
that made me afraid of hopscotch
I was already afraid of hopscotch just
because hopscotch is terrifying and
weird yeah I know I don't think I've
ever played hopscotch but anyway it back
to nightmare home Street West Craven
directed this and beforehand he had
directed movies like Hills Have Eyes and
The Last House on the Left and I feel
like he was trying to escape this
exploitation label that was being given
to him from critics because a lot of
critics were offended by Last House on
the Left because again it's disturbing
subtext and I think this movie really
helped him sort of get over that hump of
like no I'm actually a very talented
filmmaker and I can make a good movie
that isn't just about that stuff the
dream like creepy visuals in this movie
are insane like one of my favorite
sequences is the school where you see
the body and the bag gets pulled away by
like something invisible hello that
visual is phenomenal Nancy and then she
walks out into the boiler room and that
whole sequence is utterly terrifying I
mean they don't make horror films like
that anymore they I don't feel like
they're capable of making them like that
that that movie still holds up today
still terrifies me I have this to say go
watch the original Nightmare on Elm
Street in a basement at 3 o'clock in the
morning and try not to be afraid
it's the only way to watch it you can't
you can't know you're writing can make
it through it doesn't matter how tough
you are the thing that I think is most
frightening about it is the idea of you
can't fall asleep because I think for
most of us sleep is sort of like this
comforting thing like oh I'm gonna go to
bed I'm gonna get some sleep it's gonna
be nice then I'll wake up and I'll be
refreshed or whatever but if you if
you're denied that very basic thing that
we all require and you're forced to not
have it then it becomes psychological
it's not just about blood and guts and
even though some people might refer to
this as a slasher movie and I guess on
paper it is I've always viewed it more
from a psychological perspective because
of that yeah the weird thing is was
Kraven who wrote and directed this film
actually based us on real-life events
that were happening in LA there was a
guy who was having nightmares and he was
complaining about it and complaining
about it and he had a coffee maker in
his room he was staying up for days on
end and they found him dead in his room
from a nightmare and no one could
explain why Wow that was the the basis I
want to thank this film now I love when
when horror films have sort of like that
creepy conspiracy theory background
stories where how did this get inspired
where did this come from where there's
like an extension of real-life events
where the line between fiction and
reality gets blurred a little bit yeah
you know you have like the the conjuring
movies with the the Warrens
yeah loosely loosely loosely based on
you mean there wasn't like a demon woman
walking around the house there was no
doll that kill people and possess their
souls though Chucky it was real oh it's
true yeah nice and the Leprechaun and
they look specifically leprechaun in the
hood yes I wanna and in space everything
else gotta complete just rubbish I got
about space what screamed also directed
a few other horror films of the 1980s
yeah by the way
Swamp Thing that's true and I always
forget that I don't know I always forget
it be and I think that John Carpenter
directed it because it fills it feels
like a movie he made but also like the
one woman from Escape from New York is
in it and I always mix it up in my head
yeah well the other movie that lost
Kraven also directed and mean you almost
were going to do a review for them that
movie instead of this one but it's a
little movie called shocker from 1989 I
believe to me in many ways
shocker sir like the br8 version of
Nightmare on Elm Street Freddy hunter
dreams
pink or whatever his name halts cable-tv
yes
shockers incredible by the way it's
terrible yeah but also enjoyable it's so
it's garbage it's very self-aware like
it knows exactly what it's doing and
it's fine doing that and I love it for
that no here's why I remember that movie
for about three years every Friday we go
to Blockbuster and I remember walking
down the aisles and every time I walked
in the aisles the cover of that guide is
orange jumpsuit in the electric chair
always caught my eye and I always
skimmed over and one day I finally I
think
maybe like ten years old like I'm
renting this day home watched it and it
got damaged yeah and I was like yeah
that was that was pretty bad even
doesn't kiddos pretty bad Peter Berg
you're gonna go on to direct movies like
model 22 good luck
but that's right he isn't that Peter
Berg is the star of shocker that's right
he is in that fucking move and then the
final battle scene in shocker spoilers
they came out 29 years ago you have the
antagonists and protagonists chasing
each other through different channels
yeah and it's so comical yeah it gets
very common you're right it is kind of
an extension of the nightmare and I'm
straight a little it's kind of like the
beer a leftovers mm-hmm how can we kind
of take this same concept and make more
money it's sort of the cash graft your
totally right yeah but that's that's art
hey guess we didn't have to review the
movie shocker now welcome to review of
shocker and Nightmare on Elm Street a
review within a review it's weird
because when I was a kid I heard so much
about how you're supposed to be afraid
of Freddy Krueger but it was really more
of the atmosphere they built around him
in the film that scared me not so much
like seeing Freddy it was more of like
what he had the ability to do much like
Ridley Scott's alien there was something
kind of violating about it yeah we're
like it sort of touched on this primal
thing we're like this guy can get you
where you feel most safe like that's one
of the things I love about alien and how
alien is so effective to me is because
it wasn't just a monster movie there was
something kind of deeply violating about
that film like this thing's on your
mouth laying an egg inside of you and
then it bursts out of you yes we're in
this film it's like where you feel most
protected at home in your bed sleeping
in your dreams this guy has the ability
to get in there and and and throughout
the film he you know starts to find ways
to get out he's a great tormentor I mean
you you compare him to the other slasher
villains of the 1980 70s and he really
savers the flavor before he kills his
victims the one scene where he's walking
down the alleyway early on in the movie
and his arm starts stretching out to
each side of the alleyway that's
terrifying it and it's simple but it's
still so effective visually or like
coming through the wall yeah that whole
build-up to all those scenes and once
again he has one of the greatest I don't
want to use the term sanctuary but like
layers like the boiler room like just
the way he is claws go across the the
pipes and the sparks flicker and let's
talk about his prosthetics the visual
look of Freddy Krueger who's played by
Robert Englund who completely nailed it
yeah I mean you have I think it goes
almost Freddy Krueger Jason Voorhees
than Michael Myers that's who's most
most terrifying to me visually the
makeup is iconic I mean throughout the
the following movies some of them
weren't as good as others I've always
kind of enjoyed new nightmare because I
like how meta it is and how it kind of
crosses over from like reality and sort
of like combines the two and it was just
unique there's there's some good ideas
there it was almost like a precursor to
scream in a way which Kraven Nelson made
yeah it was it broke the fourth wall a
little too much that yeah out of the
lure I'll give you that but I don't mind
it I think like it's one of those
experiences where you had seen so many
nightmare films and you got to that
point where I was like alright let's do
something different let's get something
new I feel like during the 90s like
horror wasn't as iconic in film sure it
was more like television had a lot of
great horror like the x-files and you
know for kids goosebumps and are you
afraid of the dark I love how the main
character takes matters into her own
hands and it sort of reminds me of
another movie we did a review for and
that was Halloween where Jamie Lee
Curtis is tired of being the parade she
wants to become the predator yeah at the
end of this movie Nancy sets up all
these booby traps home alone style in
her house she has a huge hammer she's
ready to take Freddy out yeah and I love
that scene I mean that's that's great
that's a new build oh yeah it's I love
everything about that it's good build up
and that's something that so many horror
movies are missing nowadays is that
build up you know the suspense the
apprehension getting you invested in a
sequence and this movie has that very
well and when you get directors like
carpenter at Craven who can build up
that type of suspense and keep the
momentum and but also just make you feel
really entertained and have a good
antagonist it's like this is definitely
a cut above your average horror film
especially from the eighties I agree my
only complaint with this film is the way
it ends they leave it off were you know
the car with Johnny Depp and it's
driving off and it's a Freddy cougar
themed like drop top that comes down to
him that Freddy still around but then
his mother really
then the mother no that's fine I can
live with that it's kind of it's a dream
a sequence yeah then the mom backs up to
the door and then she gets sucked into
it and I believe even Wes Craven himself
said he he wishes he would have just
stopped it before that I've seen
remember hearing that in some
documentary or something where he
acknowledged that it should just been a
little bit more ambiguous yeah
definitely I agree with you on that and
then we got Nightmare on Elm Street too
we did I don't think I want to talk
about that movie I don't want to talk
about them are either hi I've never
liked it oh my god well man thank you
again for joining me on another one of
these reviews for our sixth annual
Halloween special John Flickinger check
out his channel link in the description
below you're good man thank you and you
know good times good people and I want
some Halloween candy now Chris let's go
let's go get some candy corn yes yes
candy corn said no one ever
no one's ever said that I have what are
you 96 years old yes are we doing here I
don't know all right guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck man eyes
you
[Music]